These two dimensional sheets of
plastic fold themselves
into 3D shapes when activated by light
Researchers printed a series of shapes onto
sheets of shrink film.
When exposed to certain wavelengths of light,
the underlying polymer heats up,
causing the plastic to fold
along these “color hinges”.
Flashing types of light in sequence
allow the sheets to fold
into complex shapes.
Red ink to green light,
cyan ink reacts to
red light,
and yellow ink to blue light.
The sheets can also be designed to react differently
to the same wavelength by
using various hues of the same color
Darker hues react more
to the light more quickly
Built in “Shape programming” like this
may have the potential
to be used in implantable medical devices
smart packaging, or even
in deploying satellites.